Digamos que tengo un frasco con un líquido
misterioso aquí y quiero averiguar qué está
sucediendo, y el primer paso es pensar: ¿ésta es
una sola sustancia o es una mezcla de múltiples
sustancias? Y me voy a enfocar en este video
en una técnica para separar las sustancias para
conocer al menos cuántas hay. Y esa técnica
generalmente se conoce como cromatografía,
pero nos centraremos en la cromatografía de capa
fina, que es la más común que podemos encontrar.
Pero otras variaciones de la cromatografía, como
la cromatografía en papel, operan con principios
muy similares. Entonces, lo que vamos a hacer
es colocar encima de algo como vidrio o plástico
una capa delgada de una sustancia polar sólida.
Ahora, lo que normalmente se hace es poner una
capa fina de gel de sílice que es la sustancia
polar sólida más comúnmente utilizada y que
también es porosa. El que sea porosa es realmente
importante, porque queremos que el líquido tenga
acción capilar y viaje a través de ella. Ahora,
el gel de sílice, como mencioné, es muy polar;
lo que vamos a hacer es tomar parte la sustancia
misteriosa y vamos a colocar un punto de esta en
el gel de sílice, luego vamos a tomar esta placa
que tiene el gel de sílice y el pequeño punto de
nuestra sustancia misteriosa y vamos a sumergir
sólo un extremo de la placa en una solución.
Y es muy importante que la solución sea menos
polar que el gel de sílice, menos polar aquí. Y
hablaremos un poco sobre lo que sucede dependiendo
de qué tan polar sea esto. Ahora, por lo general,
esta será una cantidad muy superficial de solución
que, como veremos, será una especie de solvente y
normalmente se pone en un recipiente cerrado como
este para que este líquido no se evapore. Y luego,
¿qué crees que va a pasar? Bueno, como mencioné,
esta es una sustancia porosa, por lo que habrá
acción capilar: este fluido en la parte inferior
se moverá hacia arriba a través del gel de sílice,
a través de los pequeños poros del gel de sílice.
Esta es la fase estacionaria. ¿Por qué la llamamos
así? Bueno, porque no se mueve, y puedes imaginar
que llamaremos a este solvente menos polar la fase
móvil, porque viaja a través del gel de sílice,
recoge parte de esta sustancia misteriosa y
la transporta. Y digamos que esta sustancia
misteriosa está compuesta de dos cosas diferentes,
si una parte de la sustancia es más polar
significa que se sentirá más atraída por la
fase estacionaria, que es muy polar, y entonces no
avanzará mucho; mientras que la parte de nuestra
sustancia misteriosa que sea menos polar no se
sentirá tan atraída por el gel de sílice, por lo
que viajará más lejos con el solvente. Entonces,
tal vez podría ser así, y harás esto hasta que la
fase móvil llegue a la parte superior del gel
de sílice, justo aquí. Y la razón por la que a
esto se le llama cromatografía es porque cuando
originalmente hicieron esto en realidad estaban
separando varios tejidos en la vegetación que
tenían diferentes colores. "Croma" se refiere a
los distintos colores, pero no tiene que referirse
necesariamente a cosas que tienen colores
diferentes. A veces es posible que necesites una
luz ultravioleta para verlos, pero cuando realizas
la cromatografía de capa fina verás que el
punto original se habrá desplazado varios grados
con el solvente y luego habrá múltiples puntos
dependiendo de cuántas cosas había en tu mezcla
original. Y como acabo de mencionar, esta cosa de
aquí, esta es la cosa menos polar, y va a viajar
más lejos que la cosa más polar, la sustancia
constituyente más polar, porque la cosa más
polar es más atractiva para el gel de sílice que
es estacionario. Y hay una manera de cuantificar
qué tan lejos viajaron estas cosas con relación a
tu solvente y esto se llama Factor de retención,
cuya abreviatura es F subíndice r, y se define
simplemente como la distancia recorrida por el
soluto dividida entre la distancia recorrida por
el solvente. Y debemos ser claros: no se trata
de la distancia total recorrida por el solvente,
sino la distancia recorrida por el solvente desde
este origen, desde donde pusimos el punto, justo
aquí, a partir del origen. Y permíteme etiquetar
esto como el origen. Así que, ¿qué sucede en
esta situación? Bueno, para ayudarnos a medir
tenemos que sacar una regla, entonces el Factor
de retención para la sustancia A, justo aquí,
etiqueto este punto como A, es igual a la
distancia recorrida por el soluto. Podemos
ver que viajó 1 centímetro, 1 centímetro entre
la distancia recorrida por el solvente a partir
del origen; y vemos que viajó 5 centímetros a
partir del origen. Entonces 1 centímetro entre
5 centímetros, que es lo mismo que 0.2, y luego el
Factor de retención de la sustancia B será igual a
¿qué tan lejos viajó? Bueno, viajó 3 centímetros
del total de 5 centímetros del solvente a partir
de este origen, más allá de donde pusimos esta
muestra, 5 centímetros, lo que equivale a 0.6. Así
que fíjate que en esta situación, la sustancia más
polar tiene un factor de retención más bajo que la
sustancia menos polar, y eso tiene sentido porque
la fase estacionaria es más polar que el solvente,
por lo que las cosas que son más polares son más
difíciles de mover por el solvente menos polar.